قالت اذرع العسكريه التابعه لفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مخيم جنين الى
اجتماع العقبه سيمنح الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
فرصه لارتكاب مزيد من الجرائم وانه لا يصب
في مصلحه الشعب الفلسطيني بل يمثل خدمه
مجانيه للاحتلال
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مشاركه السلطه
الفلسطينيه في الاجتماع وقالت ان هذه
المشاركه تاتي في اتجاه معاكس للاجماع
الوطني الرافد لها
ان هذا
لا يصب في مصلحه شعبنا
بل يمثل خدمه مجانيه
للاحتلال الصهيوني المجرم
الذي لا يتوقف عن الع
دوان وارضنا ومقدساتنا
ان مشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا
اللقاء
تاتي في اتجاه المعاكس
للاجماع الوطني الرافض لهذا اللقاء
والمطالب بالغائه
فالغاء هذا اللقاء هو اضعف قرار يمكن ان
تتخذه السلطه
كرد على جرائم حكومه الاحتلال